well more now on our top story that of
the protests in iraq by supporters of
shia cleric matada al-sadr mahmoud abdul
wahed joins us again live from baghdad
what's going on now then
there have been reports about casualties
uh
from
tear gas canisters that were shot at the
protesters by security forces
the
media office of the prime minister
mustafa al-qasami has just issued a
statement reiterating al-qaeda's
instructions to security forces
to keep order and maintain uh maintain
security and safety of the state
institutions
now these protesters
do not seem to be back off despite the
fact that there have been injuries from
tear gas
canisters and they say that they will
they will continue moving on towards the
green zone until the parliament responds
to their demands
these protesters have come from several
iraqi cities they're
mainly supporters of the shia cleric
they do not want the parliament to
accept muhammad sudhani as
prime minister nominated by the
coordination framework the pro-iranian
political
parliamentary bloc that is
backed by iran
now these protesters also say that they
do not trust the judiciary their
protest today is not only against the
parliament they say they do not trust
the parliament because they say that the
parliament could hold a session uh
behind closed doors so they want to put
pressure on the parliament in order not
to hold that session dedicated for
electing a new president the state and
naming a new uh prime minister they also
say that they're blaming
the supreme judiciary council
for uh for the stalemate the country has
been suffering from uh over the past few
months that's because the supreme court
gave the parliament uh the right to uh
to hold or postpone uh choosing uh a new
prison a new uh prime minister and
forming the government namely
uh the major the the southwest uh bloc
in the parliament were not able to hold
a session to
name a prime minister or former
government that is because they never
had a quorum reached in the parliament
due to
the absence of their coordination
framework
law makers so again now they're
protesting in front of the
heavily fortified
green zone and they say they seem to
escalate they want to escalate it they
want to
probably to hear instructions from their
leader mukhtar
to again once again storm uh the green
zone like as they did on wednesday when
they uh stormed also the headquarters of
the
parliament
and mahmoud with everything going on
around you where you are and with the
parliamentary session cancelled what's
likely to happen next
well there have been talks about
mediations uh the hope now is
on the mediations the under the table
negotiations between the rival political
factions there have been mediations uh
from iraq and also from regional namely
from uh from from iran uh there have
been uh reports about uh ismail khani
the commander the commander of the
iranian revolution regard puts force uh
there have been reports about uh talks
and mediations by ismail khani for the
past few days between
the rival political factions and namely
the shia rival
factions to bring them to common ground
this is an attempt from iran to
probably
heal the ref
between shia
political parties because
by political norm the prime minister is
shia since the 2005
constitution by political norm the prime
minister should be shia the president of
the state is kurd and the speaker of the
parliament is sunni so
these protesters say that they do not
trust the parliament they say they will
continue protesting and they're planning
to storm the green zone again unless
they have a guarantee they have
they guarantee that the parliament is
not accepting muhammad suddenly as
nominated for prime minister
and mahmoud we understand there's a big
security presence in baghdad at the
moment just how tense is the situation
it is it is very tense it is very tense
since uh
wednesday especially
yesterday last night these protesters
started already started coming from
several cities since last night and
there have been uh
blockings of of main roads leading to
the main square the tahrir square here
but it was opened at the last moment and
also
there have been security
security presence heavy security
presence in the area deployment of
security forces and
also security vehicles
upon request and upon instructions also
from uh prime minister mustafa al-qaeda
me who instructed the
security authorities to
keep order and maintain security and
safety of state institutions that is
especially following the wednesday uh
wednesday incident when these protesters
stormed the green zone and also stormed
the headquarters of the palm it seems
that the situation
is likely remaining very tense until
until these protesters get instructions
from their leaders okay we will have to
leave it there for a second forgive me
mahmoud
we're gonna have to leave it there for a
second forgive me
because we have
dosa jabari who is uh elsewhere on the
site actually dorso if you can hear us
what's happening where you are
well as you can see behind me there is a
portion of the wall that leads into the
green zone behind it
the demonstrators here broke down that
section of the wall a few minutes ago
and they are now going into the green
to zoom into that area you see the
concrete that is laying flat now on the
ground that was once
just a short while ago part of the wall
we're going to try to move a little bit
closer to where these demonstrators are
going in the ones that you see
the crowds walking towards this area
those are the protesters that gathered
this morning from tahrir square they are
now making their way through this area
and into the green zone the parliament
is on this side a few hundred meters
away they are hoping to reach that uh
building in the next few minutes
we understand the
aid to al-sadr has said that there
should be no bloodshed here they are
asking for the police and the
demonstrators to respect each other and
not to resort to any violence that we've
already heard of injuries that have
taken place and we also know that tear
gas has been used we can still smell it
where we're standing we're going to try
to get a little bit closer i'm going to
ask my cameraman
hider to walk with me as we move in and
you see the riot police here are
standing by
not doing anything they are allowing
these protesters who have been priestful
for the most part so far to walk in to
the green zone area they say that they
are not happy with how the government
has been handling their demands since
the elections here which took place in
october last year this is a very similar
scene to what we witnessed about three
years ago in october of 2019 when the
demonstrators at that point took over
tahrir square and they occupied it for
weeks on end now they're saying that
they don't want the
nominees that have been put forth by the
iranian-backed political groups in
parliament to be
the next prime minister they want a
different system this is what is left of
that wall i was talking about a short
while ago we're going to try to go over
with the protesters
and this is
now you're looking into the green zone
area
[Music]
[Music]
these are dramatic pictures that we're
seeing here with
calls for no bloodshed and no violence
what's the feeling you have of the mood
of the protesters there
well they seem to be very determined i
even had one of the uh demonstrators uh
show me the casing of a canister that
was fired at them and the only thing he
could convey to me he didn't speak any
english but he said this is what iran
sends to us from their country certainly
a very hostile environment towards
the iranians that have had a foothold in
this country now for quite some time
there is a sense that these demands that
they've had for years now are falling on
their ears but this time they have a
very influential and powerful cleric and
politician mukhtar al-sadr who is
very much behind them this is
their his home base this is his
supporters that are here now demanding
that they
are not going to take part in a
political system that they view to be
very corrupt and
that has other countries involved in
their political process they want their
country to be theirs and theirs only and
they want to be the only ones that have
a say in their own political process and
choose their own political leaders
including their prime minister and
president
as you say very influential cleric there
what's your sense of how long the
protesters may stay there for and how
determined they are
well i think these pictures will speak
for themselves they have been here since
early this morning and they are now
walking towards the parliament building
they're not stopping and the police
certainly are not getting in their way
we've seen since this morning it took us
about three times as long to even get to
our offices because all the main roads
in the city are blocked there is a
severe police presence security presence
across baghdad and this is why for
now they seem to be content to allow
these demonstrators to voice their
discontent we've only
heard of tear gas being fired at them
and these demonstrators as you can see
mostly young men they really just want
their demands which
to them is very basic they want
to be able to earn a decent living they
want to be able to have a say in the
political process of their country
they want their political leaders uh
that they have elected and that are not
under the influence of other countries
[Music]
i think the next few hours a few days
will be critical because
what will be happening is
there will be discussions taking place
between the different political parties
and the political leaders
to try and bring an end to this deadlock
but this is a deadlock now 10 months
going and whether or not they'll be able
to do that remains to be seen we know
that al-sadr said he was withdrawing
from the political process last month
and 73 of his mps also resigned in
protest because they said that they were
not going to take part in a corrupt
system
so whether or not they'll be able to
come to some kind of an agreement
to take to get out of this deadlock
we'll know in the next few days
hopefully but those negotiations
certainly must be taking place right now
behind closed doors and we also know
that the tool that this political
instability is taking on iraq is very
much apparent
in everyday life here there is still no
budget for this year the government has
not had a budget for 2022 that means
there is no accountability for where the
money that this country makes is going
this is of course one of the world's
biggest producer of oil
and they are one of the wealthiest
technically according to their oil sales
but being in the city and talking to
ordinary people you certainly don't see
any of that wealth being distributed
amongst the population
dorsal we can we can hear the chanting
and we can see around you there the
police
as you say apparently not becoming
involved but clearly they they look like
they are gearing up for uh well to be
prepared for all eventualities
yeah i just had my cameraman show you
the
riot police here that have lined up
they're moving in closer to the area
where we were standing
and
you can see they're quite
calm they're not keen to have any kind
of confrontation take place and i think
the general senses after what happened
in 2019 a number over 600 people died
in 2019 as a result of those
demonstrations there's certainly a
feeling here that they don't want a
repeat of that there is a
number of meetings that have taken place
by the prime minister and the president
over the past few days
to try and bring some kind of
reconciliation but i think we're going
to move out of here because the police
are let's move back let's move back
we're just going to move back so the
riot police can move in
[Music]
i think there is a sense everybody
involved they don't want this to
escalate any further but the longer this
instability goes on the longer
the possibility of that becomes a
reality
indeed and and give us a sense of how
difficult the economic situation is
which has at least partly led to some of
the frustrations that we're seeing
boiling over behind you now
yes
the last time i was here was about two
years ago and unemployment was an
all-time high and they also had of
course very difficult times with a
pandemic that was another factor
the
unemployment rate is
double digits over well over 30 percent
in iraq most of the people that are
educated are unemployed or if they are
employed
their salaries are very very low i've
spoken to doctors
who during the pandemic were really hit
hard they were working around the clock
and their salaries are a few hundred
dollars a month this is a country that
is not um like certain places in the
region where it's quite inexpensive to
live it is still very expensive
properties expensive renting is
expensive at home and the cost of daily
life is also expensive so there is a
sense that people are not reaping the
benefits of their own country's natural
resources which is oil and gas and they
say this is because of the corruption
that exists on all levels of government
not just one not just two but across the
board and they blame a lot of that not
only on the u.s led invasion which
happened here in 2003 but also on the
influence of the united states and iran
that's still very much exists in this
country there is of course also within
the the government itself the um
minorities that also have issues with
the central government in baghdad the
kurd the kurdish population in the north
of iraq they have to elect a president
uh after the elections which took place
in october and they have still not been
able to appoint a president who then is
tasked with appointing the prime
minister there is a sense that their own
divisions within that region is also
creating instabilities here so it's a
very very complicated uh situation and i
think we're seeing the results of that
unfold on the streets here
today okay dorsa jabari thank you for
that update from where you are we're now
going to uh cross back to mahmud abdel
waahed who was joining us live elsewhere
on the site forgive the early
interruption very fluid situation as you
can understand what's happening now
where you are
here if i heard you're right because
there's a lot of noise around me now
because more protesters are coming in
heading
towards the green zone this way right
behind me they're very close to the
green zone there are people already
around the green zone being pushed back
by security uh forces like my colleague
dorsal japan has just mentioned now i
have seen ambulances ambulances heading
towards the green zone and the uh sounds
of the
tear gas canisters
according to reports that there are
there are some injuries by tear gas
canisters now these protesters come from
several cities across iraq
and they
they have been chanting here since the
morning we have been chanting
against
the southern political arrivals namely
the pro-iran
coordination parliamentary block known
as the coordination framework and
despite despite
the clashes with security forces despite
the
tear gas canisters and by the violence
by defenses of the green zone
but these protesters seem to be
determined to move on they say that they
will not back off they will not pull out
unless and until
the parliament responds to their demands
they say that they do not trust the
parliament
they say that the the parliament could
probably hold that session that was
postponed
could hold it behind behind the closed
doors and they say that they
they say that we do not want to wait
until they come up with muhammad sudhani
being
nominated or being appointed as
prime minister they say that we'll
continue they will continue to put
pressure on the government until the
government responds to their demand it's
very chaotic here it's very chaotic they
have they have pulled down all concrete
walls
from
on the way from the
tahrir square in the city center on my
left until until all the way until the
green zone on my on my right
there have been ambulances heading
towards the green zone probably because
of the casualties
of the tear gas canisters
and also there have been bulldozers
heading that way probably
try to remove
the the
blocks put by security forces to prevent
the protesters
from advancing any further
or in or close to the green zone now
that's primarily realized
all that situation
i mean the solution now
primarily relies on the mediation
under the table
on the margin mediations uh between
rival factions there have been
negotiations there have been mediations
the coordination framework the pre-iran
parliamentary bloc
announced it that it is
started
it is started
under the table negotiations since
friday
whether or not this is
accurate we cannot verify for the time
being at least for now
there have been reports about
about other mediations by iran namely by
the commander of the revolutionary guard
force ismail khani he's been here in
baghdad for days now trying to mediate
between the rival factions to reach a
common ground in a way to
heal the rift between namely the shia
political person the problem now lies
within the shia political factions the
shia political factions namely between
mokhtar
on the one hand and the pro-iran
parliamentary bloc on the other hand
okay okay we're going to have to we're
going to have to leave it there
joining us live from baghdad thank you
very much for that we've been seeing
dramatic pictures of protesters at
baghdad's heavily fortified green zone
near the iraqi parliament supporters of
shia cleric mukhtar al-sadr gearing up
for another day there of those
demonstrations we'll bring you a lot
more on this as we get it here at al
jazeera for now we'll leave you with
those dramatic pictures